il me disait quand il adapte d'intérêt
que tu écris tu aurais diane vaginale
les femmes toutes des [ __ ] tout
député je vous en parle c'est que vous
êtes en jupe en tant que femme de toute
manière vous vous faites si fait des
insultes les regards des places et des
sifflets à leur passage chaque jour des
femmes sont victimes de harcèlement et
d'agressions au travail dans la rue et
les transports en commun l'un des
premiers témoignages à la télévision
c'était celui d'une adolescente en 1964
si j'ai déjà été attrapé une foire
n'en revient toujours pas
à l'époque la parole est rare le
harcèlement est peu médiatisé 1978
l'émission aujourd'hui madame aborde le
thème des agressions sexuelles notamment
dans les transports et gaillard voyais
avec la france
[Musique]
la santé mauvais mais au point de sa
lèvre
non c'est exagéré il faut attendre les
années 90 pour que la télévision
s'empare réellement du sujet 1992 le
harcèlement sexuel devient un délit la
parole féminine se libère à l'image de
cette fonctionnaire seule femme de son
service et victimes d'agressions
sexuelles au travail et puis le vendredi
22 mai à la prise de service vers 6h du
matin un de mes collègues s'est emparé
d'un rouleau à l'intérieur duquel se
trouve une affiche roulait normalement
qui fait à peu près un mètre de long sur
8 cm de diamètre et profitant que je
sois pencher pour prendre des paquets
pour trier des paquets mais l'a
carrément passé entre les fesses les
années suivantes
la télévision se fait régulièrement
l'écho d'agression sexuelle causée en
partie par les promoteurs du métro
parisien
leur technique se coller volontairement
femme pendant les heures de pointe
j'ai senti quelque chose sur moi sur une
au niveau de mes fesses dans le métro
plusieurs reprises et là comment vous
avez réagi je me suis décalé ça fait au
moins la quatrième fois que ça m'arrive
d'aller ligne 13 les images amateurs ou
de caméras de surveillance médiatise de
problème l'exemple en 2018
marie une jeune femme de 22 ans est
agressé dans la rue par un homme
j'ai lâché un ta gueule appartement où
il fait demi tour je sais qu'il va me
frapper
c'était assez violent en 2010 9 81 % des
femmes ont déjà été victimes de
harcèlement sexuel dans les lieux
publics en france
[Musique]